Раніше мільйони бджіл тут гули,
збирали пилок і переносили його у свої вулики.
Три роки тому ця вся активність у господарстві бджоляра
Костела Ґрешала припинилась.
Ви лише подивіться!
Усі бджоли мертві. Все через цю хімічну речовину,
яку вони розпорошили на полях.
Все моє бджолярство закінчилося.
Тепер я маю все це спалити.
Речовина зветься фіпроцид.
Два роки тому цим засобом обробляли пшеничні поля
через нашестя паразитів. Хоча фіпроцид
заборонено використовувати поруч з худобою.
За словами Ґрешала,  нікого з мешканців села Пуєшті,
одного з найбідніших районів східної Румунії,
не поставили до відома.
Це стало катастрофою для нас, бджолярів.
Ми втратили наш основний засіб для існування.
Бджоляр не може жити без бджіл.
Ці господарі спричинили тут справжню екологічну катастрофу.
Вони не подумали ані про людей, ані про тварин,
ані про нас. Їх цікавлять лише гроші,
якомога більше грошей.
Ґрешала втратив 24 вулики - тобто, фактично
усі засоби виробництва. Те саме трапилось і з іншими бджолярами.
Мед і сільське господарство -
це і  всі джерела доходу мешканців Пуєшти.
А ось цього чоловіка
бджоляр вважає відповідальним за смерть бджіл.
І тому подав проти нього позов за використання заборонених хімікатів.
Константін Дреґут – власник компанії,
що спеціалізується на боротьбі зі шкідниками.
Саме він два роки тому розпиляв отруту.
І хоча її вже не продає,
зате інші отруйні речовини - так.
- Дивіться: Ви можете це придбати, і тоді робить з ним, що хочете.
- Але як саме це використовувати?
- Там же написано, на пляшці.
Процес у справі Дреґута триває вже понад рік. Суд вимагає висновку
аграрного відомства. Воно ж не поспішає
із розслідуванням справи. Бджоляр здогадується,
в чому річ – директорка відомства,
що має провести експертизу, є дружиною Дреґута.
І вона захищає свого чоловіка.
Докази свідчать, що я не винен. Все було підписано, схвалено, все було добре.
Я мав знищити паразитів.
За три роки через застосування фіпроциду
тут було знищено близько п’ятдесяти мільйонів бджіл.
Отруйна речовина може нашкодити і людині.
Дія фіпроциду може бути смертельною.
Особливо коли вжити кілька продуктів, забруднених цією речовиною.
Симптоми отруєння - це нудота, пітливість, непритомність.
Через кілька років після використання отрути
природа, здається, знову відновлюється.
Костел Ґрешала виявив диких бджіл у своєму вулику.
Але чи вистачить цього надовго?